the little valley in South Africa gets
plenty of sunshine as well as rain
perfect conditions for the lush forests
and tea and fruit plantations in the
region it's this fertile landscape that
prompted citrus fruit factory letaba to
set up operations here over 50 years ago
the orange harvest is in full swing the
fruits from the plantation are delivered
to the top a factory they're sorted and
prepared for export or squeezed into
juice the production process is complex
requiring the company to use some 8,000
tons of hard coal each year now the tava
is switching to a greener alternative to
power its operations sawdust it hopes to
save a hundred thousand tons of carbon
emissions in the coming decade CEO under
his friend Vanguard tells us the big
drying oven already runs on sawdust it
comes through in a screw from the screw
it goes down into the oven that year the
lower and from the oven it goes into the
dryer the company emissions does not
exist with with the burning of the
sawdust order or the woodchips as a dust
was there with the coal
unlike coal sawdust is a sustainable
biomass fuel and carbon neutral the tons
of wet fruit peels discarded during
production are sliced and fried with hot
air and a huge drum what comes out is
high-quality animal feed it's perfect
recycling the fruit remains are simply
absorbed back into nature and that's
where the sawdust comes from to just 20
kilometers away from the factory huge
forests on the slopes are home to pine
and eucalyptus to fast growing tree
species it's little surprise then at
forestry is booming in the region the
lumber mills around the valley generate
plenty of wood shavings they form a
mountain of organic waste lumber mill
owner Rohan visagie says Libertas demand
for sawdust is a boon for his company
too I mean if they can use this stuff to
the advantage it's much better than for
me just to leave the stuff lying around
yeah so no it's on a percentage they can
help me to clean my place a bit it
sounds like a real success story but is
it really factory workers and their
families don't seem to have benefited
much from the company's greener
operations Don maaloula key lives in
housing provided by the company it's
totally run down very well not this
house is not good it doesn't have proper
sanitation we're really suffering still
the Potter plans to funnel the money
saved by the sawdust project into a fund
to provide workers with better housing
if the company does manage to link its
climate targets with real benefits for
the workers then it's green project
could indeed be a real success story